I don't want another bite but I don't
want to want another bite are you
worried over doing this to me
[Music]
a lot been we had that much you guys
like Oreos generally of course I like
Oreos dickly I like the Double Stuf
Oreos
oh is this swedish fish i love swedish
fish why is an Oreo fish and Oreos
mixing them with chocolate is something
I've never thought of
they smell like sweetest fish ready sex
no no when have you ever put chocolate
on a swedish fish I've even when I'm
drunk I kind of like it it's sweet edge
chocolatey this tastes like when you go
down the soda fountain line you just put
every single pink flavor in yeah
hilarious if you just have a cream it's
not that bad I like it it's weirdly
sharp and it's distinct and you know
what if it were in middle school I feel
like we would have had the same
experience excuse me we're drinking in
here gtfo we write one of those whoa
what do you think of it you'd be honest
be honest do hates it oh god you hate it
Ricky no I love it
that's good it's like you know when you
go to the movies and you can't decide if
you want the chocolate candy option or
you want the gummy candy option listen
Oreos I know you got cocky about you but
Swedish fishing
I appreciate what they did like it's
okay I tried that's what they need to do
days you get not a chocolate Oreo but
like a bland vanilla Oreo that has no
flavor I think maybe even L oreal would
have been better
[Music]